qui est apparue progressivement comme un
leader très suivi très écouté
[Musique]
plus à utah b est un informaticien qui a
débuté sa carrière professionnelle au
cameroun dans une entreprise
parapublique au fil du temps il a gravi
les échelons en fonction notamment de la
structuration du mouvement séparatiste
qui a donné naissance à ce qu'on appelle
habituellement la république fédérale de
l'embase au ni oui à gomme tout ça pète
we have restore down the band and we
have to discuss de thèmes voilà ici quoi
me tabih justement assurer la présidence
jusqu'en janvier 2018 date à laquelle il
a été a notamment arrêté par les
autorités nigériennes puis extradé au
cameroun avec 46 autres séparatiste
monsieur se trouve début quelques heures
les mains de la justice camerounaise
de répondre
de l'arrestation a notamment réhabiliter
sa stature et lui a permis notamment de
reprendre le contrôle sur les factions
séparatiste mais aussi il a été
notamment érigé en icône icône de la
lutte de libération que mène notamment
les mains armées sur les terrains
voilà
op rationnelle à mèze au projet
l'école et c'est au town hall est en
droit de copie forme ce tact
[Musique]